hey good morning Ned hey good morning  how is it so good how are you good dr.  weekend oh how was my weekend what'd I  do this way yeah it's good  cool man yeah well I got my coffee I'm  gonna get to it all right I'll see you  later  how's your weekend Oh what no I'm sorry  you're you're gone I'll talk to Ben who  the bike it was good though what you  again did you see Game of Thrones last  night oh no I actually don't watch Game  of Thrones oh yeah  so they call it storage wars because  people fight to get storage but I used  to go to Disney World all the time as a  kid oh that's cool  doesn't have Space Mountain yes time  about space and so I said that's not  racist you're racist yeah I need to go  to your action yeah oh oh you're walking  this way yeah yeah yeah yeah  yeah I'm actually gonna go to the  bathroom but it was good oh yeah no I'm  neither gonna bet them too